voici tout ce qu'il reste de ce pavillon
situé dans un quartier résidentiel de
bourbon lancy le feu a pris hier au beau
milieu de la nuit dans des circonstances
qui restent à déterminer
d'importants moyens ont été dégagés pour
venir à bout de l'incendié
grâce à l'intervention des pompiers de
plusieurs centres de secours du
département en corps a été découvert à
l'intérieur des décombres il pourrait
s'agir de l'un des occupants de cette
maison âgé de 27 ans qui vivait ici avec
ses parents et qui a vraisemblablement
se trouvait seul au moment des faits je
vous propose d'écouter le témoignage
d'une voisine c'est elle qui a alerté
les secours
c'était tout elles étaient en feu sur
toute la longueur et sa santé de tous
côtés c'est un faux lent c'est ça c'est
traumatise
une autopsie sera pratiquée dans les
jours qui viennent à mâcon pour
déterminer de manière certaine
l'identité de la victime acte criminel
volontaire ou accidentel c'est la
brigade de vauban ainsi et la compagnie
de charolles qui sont en charge de
l'enquêté
un nouveau drame en tout cas ici à
bourbon-lancy après une semaine
difficile pour cette commune de 5000
habitants
un jeune policier de 25 ans et au pelvis
cette semaine à paris tandis que mardi
et bien c'est une partie des termes de
la commune qui était ravagé par un
incendie